[Musik]
[Applaus]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut ich freue mich
heute auch ganz besonders weil das ist
nach bauers bestimmt habe ja drei vier
wochen wenn ich mal wieder ein neues
video
ich lese hier wirklich andauernd
kommentare alex worden konnte bitte das
nächste video und ich habe mir für heute
war es besonders rausgesucht und zwar
ist es heute gut man kann jetzt auch
nicht sagen dass er eine sache für
mädchen weil ich kenne auch wenn die
jungs ihnen glätteisen benutzen
trotzdem ist das interesse bei meinen
weiblichen zuschauern für das heutige
video denke ich mal ein bisschen stärker
als bei den männlichen ja denn es geht
um einen blättern habe ich den single
sie haben wir das gerät das wurde mir
irgendwie hier angezeigt ich bestelle ja
immer per expressversand deshalb mittels
schnell da und da hab ich gedacht kommen
nimmst es mal schnell mit flöte ich kann
es ja direkt mal zeigen
dieses gericht habe ich bestellt hat
neun euro gekostet und hat sogar eine
echt gute bewertungen wir haben vier von
fünf sternen
das ist allerdings jetzt zum ersten mal
so ein themengebiet wo ich sagen muss
okay da kenne ich mich echt überhaupt
nicht mehr aus also ich hatte noch nie
in meinem ganzen leben glätteisen ich
finde die dinge auch für mich
also ich brauche so was nicht und ich
habe auch keine ahnung wie man so was
richtig einsetzt ja aber marie ist auch
dabei also manier darf ich das gleich
mal testen und sie hat auch sein ding
deswegen haben wir schon so ein bisschen
gebündeltes wissen sein oder aber sie
ist gerade erst aufgestanden und so
sieht sie aus
aber wir brauchen ja auch nur deine
haare es geht ja heute nicht um schönes
aussehen sondern egal so also wie schon
gesagt 9 euro ist glaube ich echt sehr
sehr günstig ich habe mal irgendwann ein
glätteisen verlost das hat 160 euro
gekostet als ich das gekauft habe und
dass dinge hat sogar ein lcd display
also das für 9 euro
ich bin mal gespannt ihr steht 80 bis
200 grad schon gesagt 200 grad ist viel
zu heiß wie deine haare
das ist irgendwie so hätte ich jetzt
nicht gewusst ich habe das einfach mal
gemacht
die blondierten diese nation ach so na
ja also ich würde sagen wir schauen uns
das ding mal an haben wir noch ein paar
bewertungen sind alle eigentlich ganz
zufrieden
deswegen bin ich jetzt einfach mal
gespannt was uns hier drinnen erwartet
maximal aus also leute wir packen das
mal aus so ist es da drin hier ist es
schon leicht auf und ein bisschen okay
es war wahrscheinlich der transport auch
hin weil wenn man sich die verpackung
anschaut fällt einem schon direkt auf
das kommt aus china oder japan ich weiß
es nicht ich tendiere mal zur china also
das einzige was ich hier verstehen kann
ist fir de haas teil ja also nehmen wir
einmal den stecker das ist ein us
stecker also ich bräuchte noch einen
adapter dazu um das irgendwie benutzen
zu können
und das sieht dann so aus also auch ein
bisschen locker machen damit kann man
auch locken wochen also man kann so oder
so ich hab ich gehört dass besseren job
machen weil die fahne oben so können wir
ja mal ausprobieren oder also um ehrlich
zu sein ich habe keine ahnung was jetzt
dazu sagen soll das ist wirklich so dass
die zweite oder dritte glätteisen was
ich in der hand halte und an sich ja man
merkt schon dass das hat sich die
heftigste qualität ist aber neue euro
würde ich das jetzt auch nicht einstufen
obwohl wenn man so hier drauf rum tritt
da können schon hinkommen
ach sie haben wir noch eine beschreibung
die sieht auch nicht gerade sehr
vertrauenserweckend aus aber okay dann
würde ich sagen dass wir bereits im
kasten
ja ich hoffe dass dinge zerstört deine
haare nicht aber es wird schon irgendwie
klappen die bewertung sind ja gut glaube
das kabel ist gar nicht lange genug oder
das ist schon an
ist das jetzt gut muss das jetzt mal
einstellen ich kenne mich damit nämlich
nicht aus und jetzt soll jetzt ist an
und ich weiß nicht was das jetzt gerade
im markt ankommen ist temperaturen coupé
nicht auf das erhitzt sich jetzt gerade
wahrscheinlich oder yahoo
nein auch das ist okay und jetzt muss
ich jetzt machen ordentlich durch
[Musik]
macht ihnen das leben das man ja mach du
das liebe ich habe auch mal ausprobiert
meine haare zu glätten ich kann das gar
nicht weiß ich weiß gar nicht wo ich da
anfassen soll so mehr werden
okay ist übrigens ich habe gerade
gelesen
das ist auch einen lockenstab also hat
so mädel auch die sich locken mitgemacht
hat das stimmt aber er ist das normal
ist nicht nur weil die leute hier zeigt
man sich zu lange an einer stelle
bleiben stabil
schön oder
[Musik]
brauche ich solche priester werden
wollte jetzt noch mal so gut dass man
hier in einer dünneren strähne nehmen
zumindest hat die strähnen sie du nimmst
nochmal durch diesen erfolg note kontos
kann schon heute kennt ihr das wenn ihr
mit nassen hand einschläft also an die
mädels
und dann ja sonst habt dass ihr dann
hier so richtige wirbel habe ich auch
nicht mehr weggekommen
naja es gibt leute ist es nicht mal ob
hier jemand noch locken machen können
beziehungsweise weil ich habe keine
ahnung wie das geht also das tut mir
wirklich leid dass ich heute so rohn
informiert bin über alles aber ist halt
nur ja heute aber ich will mal sagen ich
bleibe euch vom glamour hier einen
vorher-nachher-vergleich 1
ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht
schlecht oder ja also für neun euro und
du sagst im rossmann kosten die auf 9
euro hier alle gegenseitig hätte jetzt
deutlich teurer und willst du denn sagen
das ist besser als das von und vom acker
machen machen würde ich sagen das ist
schlechter naja hier ist hier ist jetzt
nur locker war okay leute richtig das
stimmt aber das ist nicht gut für die
haare also wie gesagt ich kann mich
nicht mit aus marie sagt sie glaubt dass
das nicht gut für die haare
das war der test ich weiß ich werde euch
dann holen wollte da schreibt mir auf
jeden fall weitere produkte die ich auch
noch mal in die kommentare weil kombos
lustig ist und dass hier schenk ich dir
jetzt weil das brauche ich leute das
war's lassen nach oben da haut rein